une arrestation qui a mis le feu aux
poudres en bolivie samedi
jeanine agnès a été arrêté pour
terrorisme sédition et conspiration nous
posons est accusé d'avoir participé à
l'éviction de son prédécesseur
socialiste evo morales des milliers de
manifestants défilent dans de nombreuses
villes du pays pour soutenir l'ancienne
présidente par intérim à santa cruz
quarante mille personnes ont défilé sur
la place cristo redentor il lieu
incontournable des manifestations de la
droite bolivienne à la passe les
manifestants sont allés jusqu'aux portes
du bureau du procureur général et
dénonce un manquement à la démocratie
nous sommes vraiment de retour pour
défendre le peuple d'une dictature comme
autrefois
il y à 54'' je suis arrivé dans ce pays
pendant la dictature de bandière et
maintenant je me retrouve en vous disant
que la constitution n'a pas été vraiment
respectée à partir de là on fait des
démocraties avec des arbres un peu
boiteux acceptant tout le temps est venu
de dire assez assez assez
la femme de 53 ans et placé en détention
provisoire pour quatre mois
ainsi que deux de ses anciens ministres
evo morales appelle à des sanctions à la
suite de son arrestation pour la justice
et la vérité pour les 36 morts les plus
de 800 blessés et les 1500 personnes
arrêtées illégalement pendant le coup
d'état que soient soumis à enquête et
sanctionner les auteurs et complices de
la dictature qui a pillé l'économie et
porté atteinte à la vie et la démocratie
en bolivie evo morales a été président
de 2006 à 2010 neuf accusés de fraude
par sa principale opposante lors de son
quatrième mandat
il est contraint de démissionner après
de nombreuses semaines de manifestations
depuis ce jour l'ancien président
dénonce un coup d'état de la part de la
droite conservatrice
jeanine agnès incarcéré dans une prison
pour femmes
a dénoncé la décision de la justice
comme nous l'avons dénoncé le mas décide
et la justice obéit il m'envoie quatre
mois en détention dans l'attenté du
procès pour un coup d'état qui n'a
jamais eu lieu
delage appelle la bolivie avoir foi et
espoir
un jour ensemble nous bâtirons une
meilleure bolivie depuis sa cellule elle
demande également à l'union européenne
et à l'organisation des états américains
d'envoyer des observateurs en bolivie
afin d'évaluer de manière impartiale sa
détention